breast reconstruction helps restore the
appearance of the breast after a
mastectomy it may be performed at the
time of the mastectomy or sometime later
you and your surgeon will choose which
type of reconstructive surgery is best
for you your choices will generally
include either a synthetic implant or
one of two procedures using your own
tissue to rebuild your breasts a
latissimus dorsi muscle flap or an
abdominal muscle flap which is also
called a tram flap before the procedure
an intravenous line will be started and
you may be given an oral sedative to
help you relax
breast reconstructions are done under
general anesthesia you will be asleep
for the duration of the surgery and a
breathing tube will be inserted through
your mouth and into your throat to help
you breathe during the operation
for a lot usamos dorsi muscle flap your
surgeon will make an incision in your
upper back separate a section of tissue
and rotate the flap into position at the
site of the mastectomy
a transverse rectus abdominus maya
cutaneous flap or tram flap begins with
your surgeon making an incision in the
skin of the chest next he or she will
make an elliptical incision in the skin
fat and muscle of your abdominal wall or
if there's not enough tissue in the
abdomen in your lower back next the
surgeon will slide the tissue beneath
your skin to the mastectomy site to form
a breast Mound great care will be taken
to preserve the blood supply to the
reconstructed Mound finally your surgeon
will close the original wound on your
back or abdomen with sutures
the procedure for tissue flaps is
similar whether performed immediately or
sometime after the mastectomy the
procedure for synthetic implants however
depends on the timing of the
reconstruction if you choose to have the
implant at the time of your mastectomy
your surgeon will insert it immediately
after removing your breast tissue and
close the wound with sutures
if you choose to have the implant
surgery later your skin may need to be
stretched before the reconstruction can
occur in this case your surgeon will
reopen the incision at your mastectomy
site and insert a balloon like tissue
expander over a period of weeks your
surgeon will cause the chest wall and
skin to stretch by regularly injecting
salt water into the tissue expander
during a second operation your surgeon
will make another incision remove the
tissue expander insert a permanent
synthetic implant and close the wound
with sutures
after the surgery your breathing tube
will be removed and you will be taken to
the post surgical recovery area for
monitoring breast reconstructions are
usually inpatient procedures and most
patients remain in the hospital for one
to five days after surgery
once your breast mound is complete you
may decide to have your nipple and
areola reconstructed this is a
relatively easy procedure and can
usually be done in your doctor's office
in 30 to 60 minutes there are different
types of nipple reconstruction but one
common type involves removing tissue
from your inner thigh or ear to create a
small nipple like mound which may be
tattooed to better resemble a natural
nipple and areola this replacement
nipple is secured to the central area of
the reconstructed breast